so  what are you doing oh i was just playing  with this lamp  oh i'm star short for starbucks  assume yours is barbara nope just barb  plain old barb i want to thank barbara  stark we're hosting tonight's talking  club and we're making their hot dog soup  i like the salt i like the hat dad  it's not as runny as it usually is  what does she drink oh she gives me  bigger tea love big teeth she loves big  teeth  even if it's just two eyes on a bunch of  teeth  look my new phone case i love it it's  like i'm listening to the ocean wait we  don't have cell phones  i know i'm gonna take it home and glue  it to our landline  i'm barb and this is star roll number  again please sir 6  11. 6 11. oh my barb  oh my god she's 6 11. 6 11.  we're in 124.  you